I mentioned the New England Patriots
earlier and their deflategate scandal
now of course I looked into it this is
not the first time the Patriots have
been accused of cheating for example
there's the time they widened their own
goalposts
I don't remember that he didn't think
anyone would notice there's the time
they put magnets in the opposing teams
helmets and that caused all kinds of
trouble yeah there's the time they made
opposing teams pay tolls every five
yards there was that illegal use of a
helicopter I just thought that was
actually I thought that was brilliant
there's a time they replace one of their
linemen with a grizzly bear four people
were killed and there's the time they
put Bill Cosby in charge of the opposing
teams Gatorade that's right
[Applause]
you